dude at one point I was on so many pills
at once that my thing was I would wake
up around 3 A.M Sleepwalk till I knocked
myself out like fainting or whatever and
an ambulance would come they'd take me
to the hospital check my head do an MRI
CAT scan realize that am I okay the very
next night same thing same time I'd
knock myself out sleep well I did this
for a week straight to the point where
when I did it the the eighth time I fell
down the stairs this time and I re-broke
my elbow and wrist which was already in
the cast and I told them that uh I
really needed ambulance this time
they're like every time we call an
ambulance they always give the MRI to
let you know that you're A-Okay and they
would send me the bill which I found out
later was two thousand dollars each time
so um I was like this time I really have
to go I got I this [ __ ] is rebroken
again and uh that's when I hopped the
wall and was running to the emergency
room and then this car of like skater or
whatever well I don't know who they were
but they've recognized me like Ben what
the [ __ ] you doing I'm like I'm running
to your emergency room because I got a
broken ass up with a kid in the car dude
I can't believe in your car in my car
let us take you to the bar and have a
shot I'm like dude I haven't drank in a
year and a half and then they're like
come on just one shot I'm like no man
you gotta take they're like we'll take
you to the emergency room if you do one
shot with I'm like fine let's do a shot
so I do one shot which turns into three
or four or whatever but then I get my
x-ray thank God because that was proof
of but anyway the cops got me they
checked my breath I had alcohol on it
which got me Baker acted again I had to
go the [ __ ] loony bin once again and
um was this when you were in Florida
like
you uh went to there was like a sports
bar and then there was like a strip club
and then there was like just these weird
I don't want to like say like methy
looking people but like I met them that
day I don't know but they were like Ben
we got your back we're best friends all
this [ __ ] somebody told me do some
ketamine that they had on the on the
thing they posted that [ __ ] the very
next day sold it to TMZ I saw that yeah
you like passed out on the bed and they
were like being like just creepy over
your passed out body like just looking
really weird and creepy and it was like
very alarming and upsetting yeah yeah
um yeah dude oh that was that was rough
that was on the trip to the hospital you
did Kettering too
well we went to school
to the hospital yeah hold on
and we're there we're the strip club
coming like high noon so there was like
nothing it was the B Team
yeah did you did ketamine at the strip
club no when we went back to one of
their houses before the hospital yeah
wow and and the dude was living with his
dad who was like a preacher at a church
and he was just fed up that we were
there in like midday just still partying
he he was trying to kick us out but then
the kid was saying that uh it's my house
and it's in my name so if you want to
leave that you can it was a big [ __ ]
disaster k-hole just like oh yeah and
he's just blasting all kind of moneybagg
yo rap music and [ __ ] his dad's trying
to remember that I remember there being
like uh when did you end up going to the
hospital
um four days later somewhere in the mix
I finally West hair I got my ex right
you know I think what was crazy too is
that the last podcast we did with with
bam like we couldn't put it up right
away we recorded it in like I forget if
it was like May and then it was like
months later we put out this super old
podcast and in like the interim I think
all of this stuff happened yeah you know
like where yeah that was checked out
yeah it was kind of counter-intuitive
like what was being discussed on the
podcast didn't really line up with yeah
the meth team
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole Destroyer lawyer
and Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude